bonjour bienvenue sur tv 78 radio
sensations yvelines pour ce nouveau
débat en vue des élections municipales
les électeurs ont rendez vous aux urnes
les 15 et 22 mars prochain nous
accueillons pour cette émission les
candidats de la commune de coignières au
22 février jour d'enregistrement de
cette émission
ils sont 2 est officiellement déclarée
et vont débattre de leurs programmes en
plateau et je rappelle que pour ces
débats les temps de paroles seront
chronométrés s'afficheront régulièrement
au cours de cette émission et je précise
aussi qu'un tirage au sort a été
effectué pour permettre et déterminer
lequel de ces candidats allait
s'exprimer en premier essai vous xavier
girard bonjour bonjour qu'ils allaient
commencer ce débat vous êtes cadre du
secteur automobile vous êtes la tête de
liste est de coignières à venir une
liste sans étiquette en décembre 2018
elle vous étiez en 25e position sur la
liste du même nom qui était porté lors
d'une municipale partielle candidature
mené à l'époque par ali bousselham
ancien maire-adjoint
pourquoi être candidat tête de liste et
pourquoi vous choisir vous êtes très
bonne question mais je vous remercie de
l'invitation sa du monsieur fisher aussi
présents je pense que c'est nécessaire
de revenir sur ma candidature de façon
relativement importante dans cette
émission puisque clairement nous sommes
je suis un nouveau candidat sur une
nouvelle liste puisque là que 18 mois
d'existence à quoi me ravir donc pour ma
part effectivement donc je suis cadre de
services automobiles
ça fait onze ans que je suis sur
coignières dans le cadre d'une mutation
professionnelle
j'ai choisi coignières dont les cinq
villes que me proposait mon employeur
parce que la ville m'a beaucoup plu
ainsi une ville atypique ça va plus le
côté environnemental le côté commerce et
le côté service avec les écoles à
proximité c'était une ville vraiment
attrayante j'y étais elle est toujours
attrayantes et ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'en avril donc il va intéresser
d'euros tirant de loin de transition
politique s'avère quand on a vu et 2018
il ya eu un projet de fusion au repas
nous sommes retrouvés dans la rue
clairement puisque nous étions contre le
projet en tout cas comment elle été
communiquée prononcé et la vitesse et
précipitation qu'on nous a donné
l'information donc au mois de mai ce
projet a été retiré
entre deux dunks one year à venir s'est
fondée donc c'est au départ l'affront de
la mesure était municipal le super
approché par les frondeurs
une fois deux fois trois fois en
septembre ils sont venus me voir pour
dire qu'il y avait des élections et qui
souhaitait me voir sur les listes
électorales par rapport à ce que je
pouvais apporter à la liste donc je me
suis laissé convaincre par leur discours
donc incorporé à la 25e place que me
l'avait précisé
cette liste bon il s'avère qu'on nous
sommes bien comportés puisque on s'est
retrouvé en seconde position derrière
monsieur m'a dit monsieur fisher donc à
42 % ce qui est très honorable points
distincts qui avait aucune existence
quelques mois avant on a continué à
travailler sur sur corner à venir avec
cinq conseillers puis 4 puisque monsieur
les goûts si dame nous a quittés pour
raisons personnelles très clair dans six
mois c'est juste que vous êtes à deux
minutes de temps de parole mais allez-y
aucun souci c'est je souhaite prendre la
parole parce que clairement en tant qu
il vaut au candidat je suis pas connu
une de beaucoup de cognin encore donc
j'ai repris la liste connue en juin pas
très clair départ de monsieur ali
bousselham et puis nous semblait
indispensable de faire une opposition
actuellement à la destin monsieur fisher
tout simplement parce que il n'y avait
aucun d'opposants en titre la liste de
la liste est composée actuellement de
27 personnalités dont une seule a été
conseiller municipal
donc c'est une liste complètement
nouvelle elle est composée de personnes
des employés des ouvriers des cadres du
public du privé donc des gens qui ont
envie de faire des choses - konya c'est
vrai ça sort vraiment de l'élan quoi ni
rien et non qui m'ont élu président
parce qu'il semble que je suis plus à
même de mener cette liste voilà pourquoi
clairement je suis candidat voilà parce
que des coins dernière me l'ont demandé
nous on demandé que la voix des
comédiens soient représentés suite au
mouvement de rassemblement populaire qui
est du mois d'avril on peut dire
maintenant on appelle ça un ralliement
un ralliement d'initité d'initiative
citoyenne
voilà je suis le candidat de ce
mouvement populaire mode introduction
également pour vous didier fischer
bonjour vous êtes maire sortant de
coignières sans étiquette
vous avez été élu en décembre 2018 lors
d'une élection partielle rendue
nécessaire après la démission de
jean-pierre sevestre et de plusieurs
autres élus têtes de listes pour ce
scrutin d'un élan durable pour
coignières même question que pour xavier
gérard pourquoi être candidat et
pourquoi vous choisir à nouveau pour
cette élection tu es ma candidature
s'inscrit dans un contexte qui avait été
déjà un contexte particulier lors du de
l'élection de décembre puisque comme l'a
rappelé mathieu girard que je salue bien
entendu ici en face de moi sur ce
plateau
nous étions dans une situation quand
même de crise politique importante sur
la ville de coignières liés à la fusion
et c'est vrai que j'avais été moi même à
l'initiative du collectif qui avait en
quelque sorte mener cette lutte contre
la fusion contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur girard peut-être là sur ces
questions de fusion moi j'étais
intrinsèquement contre intrinsèquement
contre avec des arguments pas seulement
sur la forme mais sur le fond les quoi
n'ya rien allez souffrir de cette fusion
faut pas oublier non plus que c'était
quand même 65 % d'augmentation de la
taxe foncière la fusion avec maurepas
c'était devenir un quartier de maurepas
une ville comme coignières se pense
comme un village et à une histoire et
c'était cela qu on y est dans le cadre
de la fusion est ce pour cela que je me
suis dressé effectivement contre cette
fusion
alors évidemment j'ai été élu en ce que
les poignées rien on constaté en effet
je dirais ma bonne foi et je dirais ma
détermination dans ce domaine là ensuite
je n'étais pas un inconnu dans la mesure
où cela faisait quand même une bonne
dizaine d'années que je vivais à
coignières je suis arrivé premier en
2007 en septembre 2007
et très vite je me suis impliqué dans la
vie politique
quoi
aérienne en tant qu'un des leaders en
effet de l'opposition à l'époque à
monsieur cailleux et ensuite monsieur
sauvestre et à plus forte raison
évidemment au moment de la fusion mais
une opposition qui a toujours été je
dirais courtoise et comment dire nos
positions constructives
on s'est toujours inscrit avec mon
groupe dans une opposition constructive
dans le fait de proposer quand on
n'était pas d'accord avec quelque chose
est bien en proposer autre chose
c'est dans cette logique là finalement
que naturellement j'ai été amené au mois
d'octobre novembre à déposer ma
candidature et être candidat donc à
cette élection partielle
et c'est vrai que sans des urnes a été
une victoire aujourd'hui il faut
poursuivre cet élan
on avait fait la promesse au poignet un
lien de ramener la sérénité en ville je
pense qu'aujourd'hui cette sérénité
elle est retrouvée on avait aussi fait
la promesse au poignet rien de redonner
un élan en quelque sorte à l'action
municipale je pense qu'aujourd'hui vu le
bilan que nous avons
c'était lent il est réel et cette action
municipale
je dirais aller constater aujourd'hui
par une grande partie quand même des
quoi dit rien donc ce que je demande
simplement en étant candidat aujourd'hui
c'est de poursuivre cet élan
en fait on est dans cette logique de
poursuivre cet élan et de s'inscrire non
plus dans un nouvel élan mais dans un
élan durable et c'est tout le sens de ma
candidature
coup d'oeil sur les temps de parole vous
êtes environ tous les deux à trois
minutes de temps de parole
voilà pour l'introduction de ce débat
avant de poursuivre regardons est les
principaux enjeux pour cette campagne
des municipales à coignières ils sont
présentés par michael et demi d'euros
coignières une commune de moins de 4500
habitants avec une double identité
urbaine et rurale
c'est dans cette optique que la ville
souhaite intégrer le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
coignières pourrait avoir un statut de
ville porte en 2023 intégrer le pnr
permettrait de valoriser son patrimoine
et notamment son église ainsi que ces
espaces naturels
autre enjeu la destruction du silo aux
abords de la résidence des acacias du
centre commercial le silo servait de
parking mais il a été muré par le
bailleur en 2012
les voitures ne pouvaient plus y garer
conséquence le quartier manque de places
de stationnement la structure devrait
être démolie dans les prochains mois
pour aménager un parking et un square de
zones commerciales sont également
repenser les portes de chevreuse et le
forum jb secteur est au coeur d'une
étude globale de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines pour
redynamiser cette zone commerciale avec
celle de paris ouest à maurepas une zone
commerciale traverser notamment par la
nationale 10 comme pour la commune de
trappes lax coupe la ville en deux
la flexion devrait être menée sur la
requalification une rénovation du
carrefour de la malle me donne est
notamment à l'étude et concernera
coignières la verrière et mon repas
enfin coignard a intégré saint quentin
en yvelines en 2016 à doit aujourd'hui
imaginer ces futures collaborations avec
les communes de cette agglomération ces
dernières années la ville a abandonné
son projet de fusion avec maurepas en
coignard a également mis fin à la police
municipale avec maurepas après un an
d'existence et la commune n'a pas
intégré le projet de centre aqualudique
avec maurepas elancourt voilà pour ces
enjeux dont nous allons aborder une
grande partie dans ce débat premier
thème c'est la préservation de
l'environnement et du cadre de vie à
coignières c'est une commune de près de
4400 habitants à cheval entre l'urbain
et aussi avec cette grande zone
commerciale 1 qui est-ce qui se partage
avec paris mais c'est aussi la campagne
les habitants sont attachés à préserver
l'identité de ce village de coignières
on l'a vu lors du projet de fusion
avortée avec man pas vous l'avez évoqué
il ya une grosse opposition au sein de
la population et qui a conduit
indirectement à ces élections partielles
de novembre et de décembre 2018 didier
fischer vous souhaitez vous voir entrer
alors sur cette thématique de
l'environnement la commune dans le parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse coignières pourrait avoir un
statut de ville porte à partir de 2023
est ce que c'est un levier intéressant
le fait d'intégrer ce parc pour
préserver justement ce cadre de vie cet
environnement après sa mort c'est même
essentiel d'intégrer le parc
on est dans une
logique en effet territoriale même 1
coignières est aux portes du parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
que kony redevienne une ville porte ou
même que coignières intègre le parc
parce que bon l'idée est peut-être de
devenir une ville porte d'ici 2023
notre 2023 et 2026 vous avez la révision
de la charte du pnr et cette révision de
la charte peut nous amener en effet à
proposer notre candidature en fait pour
intégrer le parc naturel de la haute
vallée de gilles porte on précise c'est
un statut intermédiaire c'est un statut
en effet intermédiaires qui donne
quelques un avantage évidemment à la
commune un le fait d'être ville porte ce
n'est pas rien bien entendu pour aimer
ça peut aussi présager une intégration
ensuite futur dans le pnr et je pense
que s'il faut que nous allions vers cela
parce qu'en fait intégrer le pnr c'est
d'une certaine manière profiter aussi
des avantages de l'ingénierie par
exemple du parc
c'est aussi redonner une image une autre
image en fait à notre commune communes
traversées par la nationale 10 communes
aujourd'hui avec des zones d'activités
on en parle et qui se dégrade
tout cela ne donne pas l'impression en
effet d'être une commune à la pointe
aujourd'hui de l'environnement
cela dit c'est une fausse impression
parce que les poignées rien savent très
bien où on y vit bien un poignet je
prends à témoin monsieur girard ici
présent les coigné rien savent convient
bien à coignières savent que derrière la
nationale 10 il ya un village agréable
savent qu'il y à 70% pratiquement 70% de
la commune qui sont des espaces naturels
des terres agricoles des bois et qu'on
n'ait jamais à moins de dix minutes est
en quelque sorte des bois ou des champs
quand on habite coignières donc on a une
qualité de vie qui est quand même très
acceptable alors cette qualité de vie
bien entendu il faudra qu'on améliore et
c'est l'objet de nos programmes enfin
tout au moins du mien en l'occurrence
d'essayer d'améliorer bien entendu cette
qualité de vie mais je crois qu'il faut
qu'on s'inscrive non pas dans du
greenwashing parce que c'est souvent ça
le
le cas aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
environnement amélioration du cadre de
vie ainsi de suite
soit qu'il faut avoir une pensée
beaucoup plus globale et se penser comme
une ville en transition et c'est bien
cela et se rapprocher par exemple à ceux
qui est le pacte de la transition
écologique est aujourd'hui dans les
propositions que nous faisons que mon
équipe et moi même faisons est bien une
bonne vingtaine finalement entre dans
cette perspective du pack de la
transition écologique c'est à dire c'est
celle à venir de poignard cela une
certaine façon on va transformer notre
commune progressivement des choses ont
déjà été faites on ne part pas de rien
moi je ne nie pas tout ce qui a pu être
fait par les autres équipes mais je
crois que résolument maintenant il faut
s'engager dans d'autres perspectives et
intégrer le pnr s'est pas seulement
symbolique sait déjà c'est déjà mettre
le pied dans cette transition écologique
il géra risque intégrer le pnr pourrait
être intéressant ce que vous avez aussi
d'autres propositions pour préserver cet
environnement et ce cadre de vie à
coignières pense que oui on est enfant
on peut être que d'accord pour de
rentrer dans le pnr évidemment nous
avons d'autres propositions notamment
d'aménager certaines zones qui sont des
zones laissées en désuétude comme le
quartier des acacias
il faut travailler avec france
habitation faudra ménager cette zone qui
clairement à un espace vag laissé à
l'abandon
donc là dessus on a des propositions on
a des propositions pour rénover les
parcs on a le parc d'après landry qui a
aussi dans un état gyr est déplorable
on a un aire de jeux pour enfants qui
est adapté on a un espace qui
complètement laissé vivre on a un gros
projet sur park d'après vandry nous faut
mettre un certain nombre de choses y
avait un projet qui était vandry savait
très bien qu'on y travaille en ce moment
sur le projet si c'est vrai c'est pas
nouveau la pré vendre il après vandrisse
et le paris de l'après vandry c'était
une demande des conseils des conseils de
quartier donc c'est une demande des
conseils de quartier qui a été prise en
compte en effet et aujourd'hui on a on
est en train de faire les études
nécessaires et collectivement pour
réaménager ce parc de l'appréhender je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
ces jouets sont enfin cesser jeux pour
enfants sont aujourd'hui
je dirais dans un état assez déplorable
il n'y a pas eu d'entretien et un rien
eu il faut effectivement revenir
d'ailleurs il faut redessiner
complètement le parc
aujourd'hui ça c'est sur les mêmes
sujets si vous êtes un petit portant sur
le temps de parole sur ses thèmes
attiyah je suis surpris parce que il ya
un projet sur les acacias
il ya eu ce silo là un vrai projet la
destruction du mur du silo et on va
laisser monsieur jacques s'exprimer sur
cette thématique de l'environnement
vous êtes surpris mais bon encore
faut-il le dire
les deux silos c'est qu'une étape
clairement elle est bien insuffisante
comme le président est monsieur fisher
pour ce quartier des acacias
justin permis de détruire donc ces gens
dans un un permis d'aménager on a permis
de destruction d'un permis d'aménager
mathieu girard
je vais vous demander de vous laisser
chacun la parole les allées du
mutualiste ebs et à quatre millions de
noms de parole voilà donc oui si je peux
m'exprimer
non mais clairement donc il ya un
certain nombre de choses à faire
notamment également dans les résidences
aménager des parcs de jeux parce qu'il y
en a pas il ya l'aménagement on en parle
c'est peut-être un peu concernant le val
fabrique donc parler comment travailler
que saint quentin en yvelines le val
favery fait partie du bien mais de saint
quentin en yvelines il ya des choses à
faire puisque là aussi il ya aucun
aménagement sur cet espace là on l'
environnement c'est aussi la cuisine
avec la cuisine centrale qu'on a imaginé
pour nos enfants il faut parler des
circuits courts du bio mais encore
faut-il avoir la main sur son sur le
circuit donc on pense également aménager
une cuisine centrale pour la rpa et pour
les écoles de notre ville s'est
également aménagés
des voies de circulations douces et
c'est là dessus nous avons également
pensé à subventionner tout un sens de
choses comme des vélos électriques moi
il ya des âmes des idées on en a
beaucoup
le programme il va être une impression
distribué la semaine prochaine sans
occasion de le voir dès la semaine
prochaine avec nous différents candidats
alors on peut d'ores et déjà deuxième
thématique puisque on avance dans cette
émission si on veut avoir le temps
d'aborder toutes les thématiques vous
pourrez revenir vous avez un mot de
thématiques libre à la fin de cette
émission déjà coup d'oeil sur les temps
de parole et xavier girard vous êtes à à
5 minutes 28 didier fischer 6 minutes 40
et une et on va aborder maintenant la
deuxième thématique et l'économie et
l'emploi coignières en plus d'être une
commune de campagne à sur son territoire
deux zones commerciales les portes de
chevreuse et le forum jib est une zone
commune avec celle de paris-ouest ans
sur la commune de maurepas l
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines dont coignières un fait partie
a lancé d'ailleurs une une réflexion
pour repenser cette zone commerciale
on va commencer avec vous et xavier
girard est-ce qu'il faut repenser
justement cette zone commerciale quelles
sont vos propositions en la matière sur
l'économie et donc là on parlera de
l'emploi juste après mais d'abord sur
les côtes corses auraient commis en fait
les deux les deux sont liés y a pas
d'emploi sans économie et visions ça
donc sur l'emploi enfin sur l'économie
clairement sur les deux parcs qui sont
nos périmètres de saint quentin en
yvelines
oui on peut être que d'accord on a un
consensus on s'est rencontrés dans les
ateliers 36 rotation avec l'équipe de
monsieur fisher ya qu il ya des
aménagements à faire
l'accessibilité de lisibilité des zones
où il manque vraiment
par thématique il faut aménager les
zones on sait très bien que le commerce
traditionnel est en perte de vitesse
donc il faut aussi repenser tout ce
processus commercial mais c'est surtout
penser aux autres commerces
c'est ça qui m'inquiète beaucoup de
sueur coignières il ya tout des zones
comme la zone des 1 va la zone qui se
trouve derrière la nationale 10 qui est
vraiment également très abîmée elle
n'est pas d'un périmètre dans de saint
quentin en yvelines
et là il ya un vrai sujet avec les
commerçants alors sur sur l'économie on
pense travailler main dans la main avec
le club des entreprises dont je fais
partie de plusieurs depuis plusieurs
années donc quand je vous dis qu'à un
sens avec l'emploi il est là c'est à ce
moment là et ce qu'ils comptent faire
comme proposition s'amener saint quentin
en yvelines à travailler avec nous pour
créer pépinière d'entreprises sur la sur
la zone de coignières de faire d entre
eux là c'est non c'est également une
proposition de monsieur fisher de faire
du coworking c'est à dire un espace de
travail partagé faut savoir qu'il ya
beaucoup de micro entrepreneurs de
petites entreprises voire de très
petites entreprises
et c'est là que vient à l'emploi et puis
ensuite clairement il faut un forum
et c'est là on rejoint l'emploi enfin un
forum commun un endroit spécifique où
les gens de la mairie où les gens de
saint quentin en yvelines où les
employeurs se rencontre de façon fixe et
puissent échanger sur les emplois sur
les stages à proposer là on précise
qu'il ya déjà un forum de l'emploi on
utilise des routes chakana coillard il
faut peut-être l'étoffé on va voir ça
avec monsieur fisher déjà aussi aux
propositions sur l'économie avant de
parler de l'emploi
cette zone commerciale et ce qu'il faut
effectivement la repenser ce que vous
avez des propositions pour redynamiser
aussi les commerces de proximité
bien sûr on en met effectivement cette
saison' d'activité sur coignières sont à
repenser ses des zones vieillissante
c'est une conception qui auraient des
années 80 90
et aujourd'hui ça ne fonctionne plus on
le sait bien on sait bien que les
nouvelles les nouveaux modes de
consommation font que cela ne fonctionne
plus ou tout au moins est en perte de
vitesse
alors c'est pas encore catastrophique
mais je crois qu'il faut agir avant que
ça le devienne
c'est ça le fond du problème
effectivement il ya tout un travail qui
est menée aujourd'hui avec saint quentin
sur paris ouest le forum j bay et les
portes de ce gredin ces salles périmètre
aujourd'hui de l'étude moi j'ai plaidé
dans le cadre je dirais de ce travail
pour qu'on est en notre regard au delà
on ait une vision beaucoup plus globale
qu on englobe notamment toute la partie
des broderies et la partie aussi de la
latérale sud afin qu'on est je dirais
une action qui soit une véritable action
sur ces commerces et sur ses zones
d'activité alors quoi faire
le problème il est là 1 qu'est ce que
l'on propose qu est ce que l'on va faire
sur ces zones d'activités faut repenser
la manière de je dirais la manière de
vivre dans ces zones d'activités en fait
pour reconstruire la ville sur la ville
il ne faut plus penser en termes de zone
aujourd'hui c'est fini ça il ya plus un
géographe ya plus un comment dire
quelqu'un qui pense aujourd'hui le
laisse passer le territoire en termes de
zone c'est fini en fait faut le penser
en termes de ve il faut le penser en
termes d'aménagement foyer a mené les
circulations douces notamment
il faut il créer des tiers lieux il faut
y mettre de la végétalisation faux faux
végétalisée ces lieux il faut faire en
sorte que les consommateurs aient
plaisir à aller dans ces zones
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui quand on
allait vous avez pu voir les études qui
ont été faites par saint quentin sur ce
sujet on voit bien qu'on y va à reculons
on y va parce qu'on est obligé d'y aller
parce qu'on va y trouve effectivement ce
qu'on y cherche mais on y va souvent à
reculons d'où la difficulté d'ailleurs
d'un certain nombre de ces entreprises
et notamment tout ce qui est hyper
marché enfin puisqu'il est grande
distribution aujourd'hui et
gravement difficultés alors moins mon
souci c'est pas seulement effectivement
les zones d'activités c'est aussi le
commerce de centre-ville qui a quasiment
disparu de notre commune du fait
justement de cette ceinture
de cette ceinture commerciale autour de
la ville alors le commerce de proximité
il faut leur lancée il faut un véritable
plan et c'est ce que nous proposons en
ce qui concerne ce commerce de proximité
et là je pense que la municipalité a un
rôle à jouer avec 50,1 mais c'est pas
dans la compétence le commerce de
proximité n'est pas dans la compétence
de l'agglomération ont la compétence de
l'opération c'est l'économie d'une
manière générale et les zones des
grandes zones d'activités donc mais
malgré tout la réflexion avec
saint-quentin est évidemment essentiel
dans ce cadre là et je pense que l'on
peut redynamiser notre commerce de
proximité
alors qu'on revenir aux acacias je sais
que vous proposez diffère du logement
les faire des choses de ce type
j'ai vu ça dans un an dans un dans un
article dans la presse je crois que
c'était la gazette de saint valentin
c'est juste vous verrez bientôt a dit
mis de temps à la rolls dans la gazette
de saint quentin
en effet cet espace doit être réaménagée
mais moi je ne veux pas faire de la
densité jeu pas bétonner le centre ville
aujourd'hui de coignières je pense qu'il
faut mieux repenser finalement
je dirais le logement à travers
notamment le réaménagement entre
guillemets de nos zones d'activités
on va reconstruire la ville sur la ville
on va mêler de l'activité économique et
du logement
c'est la seule manière à mon avis de
réussir en fait cette transition et
c'est une véritable transition
écologique ce dont tu parlais tout à
l'heure avec des projets liés on va vous
donner par le monsieur gérard peut-être
vous entendre sur l'emploi vous en
parliez tout à l'heure
ap coignières en tout cas il ya un taux
de chômage qui est à cvs par rapport au
reste des yvelines aux alentours de 15%
comment le faire baisser vous parliez
tout à l'heure de davantage de
collaboration peut-être avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
ça va faire la transition avec notre
thématique d'ailleurs venir sur un point
de monsieur fisher de hors de question
de bétonner centre ville je pense que la
quiproquo clairement il faut reprendre
ne sait pas on n'a pas encore votre
prénom on est exprimé dans la presse en
disant on va construire du logement à
cet endroit là donc
alors voilà presse ne vous a pas empêché
de regarder dans la thématique livre
alors ça vous demander de parler juste
de l'emploi à lisier paul de lay section
de bétonner que vous dit en fait il faut
recréer un centre ville enfin il faut
créer un centre ville puisqu'il n'ya pas
de centre-ville à poigne et je pense que
ça peut être un lieu des spasmes
notamment il ya des commerces de
proximité
il existe de très beaux bâtiments en une
ou deux étages où on peut allier des
commerces de proximité en rez de
chaussée et des appartements sur le
premier et deuxième étages sans que ça
fasse du bétonnage clairement on a un
manque de logements cruel sur la ville
ancien du t2 t3 on n'a pas du tout ce
genre de logement s'ils ont reconnu hier
du coup les jeunes ménages ne viennent
pas s'installer à coignières cette fois
est une solution est également le
quartier de la gare vous préféré aborder
si vous voulez à la fin de cette
émission je vais vous demander ce que
l'économie a certes l'économie l'emploi
très clairement il ya beaucoup d'emplois
atypiques sur la ville je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de métiers inconnu également
par par des concitoyens
quand vous discutez avec les commerçants
donc je fais partie c'est clairement un
10 jeux xavier je ne te propose pas tel
emploi haute et l'emploi parce que
clairement je ne trouverai pas donc un
moment donné il n'ya pas l'interface qui
se créent et pourquoi l'interface elle
se crée pas je veux dire simplement
parce que au niveau des employés
municipaux ça se trouve dans la
municipalité et les commerçants se
trouve sur l'autre oreille il faut
réunir les deux entités et veut créer un
forum commun qu'ils soient créés de
façon partenariale et c'est là dessus
que je pense avoir pas mal d'idées
parce que j'ai travaillé dans le
recrutement sur coignières donc je peux
apporter des choses je peux apporter des
choses vis-à-vis des demandeurs d'emploi
pour travailler sur un projet
professionnel
je peux apporter des choses auprès des
commerçants pour associer ses projets
avec leurs réalités du terrain et ça
commence également par les stages voilà
je ne suis pas pas mes enfants font des
stages c'est très difficile de trouver
des stages si vous n'avez pas un carnet
d'adressés quasiment impossible voilà je
vous dis des choses si vous connaissez
pas le monsieur qui connaît et donc là
dessus excusez moi là dessus il est
possible également
faire de trouver des solutions il ya
beaucoup de jeunes entreprises qui
recherchent le site des stagiaires et
c'est là premiers peuvent vers l'emploi
voilà didier fischer vous votre position
vous avez vous lancé une réorganisation
du service d'aidé à l'emploi fait tout à
fait on a il y avait rien il faut être
clair en ce qui concerne l'emploi sur
poignet quand on est arrivé il y avait
quasiment rien il y avait aucun lien là
il y aurait que les entreprises ça aussi
c'est un vrai souci les âges rejoint
monsieur girard
c'est évident qu'il faut travailler main
dans la main avec les entreprises et une
idée de forums effectivement été plutôt
une bonne idée et ingénieurs en ce qui
concerne en ce qui concerne le lien que
l'on peut avoir avec le milieu
économique local et pas seulement le cal
d'ailleurs il faut le penser à l'échelle
mon avis au moins de l'agglo au moins de
l'agglo alors c'est dans cet esprit là
qu'on travaille depuis le mois de
décembre il faut pas penser qu' on est
complètement à côté des réalités
économiques et de l'emploi de notre
commune on y vit depuis un moment c'est
comment les choses se passent moi j'ai
trouvé une situation qui était quand
même assez catastrophique dans ce
domaine là il faut quand même rappeler
coignières c'est une ville de 4400
habitants où il ya 5500 emplois en fait
en fait il faut pas non plus oublier
cela
donc et on pourrait se dire finalement
les poignées rien trouvent tous l'emploi
dans le secteur
c'est pas vrai 15 % de nos concitoyens
sont aujourd'hui au chômage donc il ya
un vrai problème et c'est pour ça qu'on
a mis en place un véritable service de
l'insertion professionnelle c'est pour
ça que je suis allé rechercher des
professionnels pour faire ce travail et
aujourd'hui ça fonctionne on suit plus
d'une centaine de personnes et on a dû
retour à l'emploi
on commence à avoir des liens de plus en
plus solides avec les entreprises et le
tissu économique local et ça ça commence
à fonctionner vraiment un et j'ai une à
une adjointe justement à l'économie et à
l'emploi
florence rocard qui a travaillé chez we
4 4 cas je dirais à tout un parcours en
fait intéressant niveau de l'entreprise
et qui fait ce travail aujourd'hui et
qui le fait plutôt bien et on va
continuer bien entendu notre proposition
c'est d'accroître évidemment cela c'est
d'améliorer encore les relations avec le
milieu local avec le tissu économique
local afin d'être plus performant
évidemment pour nos demandeurs d'emploi
alors on arrive déjà à 30 minutes
d'émission ne va pas avoir
malheureusement le temps d'aborder le
dernier thème qui était coignard dans
saint quentin en yvelines je rappelle
que coignard a intégré cette
agglomération de 50 ans dit on en a
parlé au cours de ces débats
son centre en 2016 on fera un dernier
tour de table alors je rappelle juste
les temps de parole 12 minutes 27 pour
didier fischer et déjà vous êtes à 9
minutes 28 dont vous aurez un peu plus
de temps pour conclure ce débat libre à
vous de d'aborder la thématique de votre
choix vous pouvez aborder cette
thématique de coignières dans 50 en
yvelines revenir sur une thématique qui
a été abordé au cours de ce débat ou
tout simplement quelques mots de
conclusion également on va commencer
avec vous xavier gérard pour cette
conclusion du débat et à les y voilà
donc le lieu de présentation qui ont été
faites on a beaucoup de consensus avec
l'équipe à monsieur fisher elle n'a pas
encore eu notre programme et il ya
beaucoup de choses en commun
on a une différence sur sur la vision
dans son programme c'est un choix qu'a
fait monsieur fichiers aura sa liste
c'est un programme sur six ans c'est un
programme à chaque page je m'engage sur
six ans donc c'est un contrat social et
j'entends son choix on a opté pour une
vision plus large sur sur deux parfois
deux à trois mandatures sur des projets
plus fondateurs ont ça c'est un saint ce
choix qui veut que nous avons fait sur
les 65 mesures que nous allons mettre en
place je pense qu'il y en a une
trentaine en commun je pense que les
sujets qui n'ont pas été évoquées
notamment le cas fort malden la dizaine
commerciale
on est d'accord sur le sujet on
travaille de en commun avec monsieur
fisher à ces équipes là dessus il ya pas
de problème sur l'histoire de de
l'environnement bien sûr sur
l'environnement c'est vraiment un sujet
que qui tient à coeur tous les poignets
rien on se retrouve d'accord sur le pnr
on propose des actions de prévention on
propose également des actions par pour
la sécurité sécurité domestique des
enfants voilà on veut créer on veut
créer un service civique par rapport à
ça au niveau du bétonnage non ils n'ont
pas plus de bétonnage si on sur la ville
on veut créer un coeur de ville
un coeur de ville qui n'existe pas
on a une population vieillissante sur le
centre ville nous semble nécessaire nous
semble nécessaire de faire en sorte
qu'il ya des commerces de proximité
on veut créer un pôle multiservices au
sein de la mairie qui reprendrait le ccs
et différents intervenants notamment des
intervenants en psychologie en des
intervenants sur des associations à la
diction sur les méfaits de la drogue se
permettra de nom cette nouvelle maison
intergénérationnelle n'est pas d'après
vandry non monsieur fisher se targue
d'avoir eu l'initiative de créer cet
espace que les parents ont besoin
voilà notre sujet et 20 autres sujets je
dirais notre venir admirer vraiment basé
sur la famille donc on va énormément
insisté sur le problème pardon je
voulais c'est terminé je vous laisserai
j'ai juste une précision
vous parlez du parc d'à peine maison du
parc de la présente rhénan maison
intergénérationnelle rimmel talent et du
tarif de la présent de rire avec une
maison du parc de la présente rien non
une maison alors des nationalistes une
pression externe est que vous aviez vous
aviez parlé on
l'idée c'est de la craie au niveau du
parc de combrit sait faire dans le parc
de l'après vendre il amène donc voila
tout à fait souvent non mesdames et
messieurs aérien
voilà voilà non mais c'est ce que je
voulais vous faire dire à londres et
dans le cas présent dry bien voilà c'est
un choix non mais vous vous êtes laissé
monsieur gérard conclure alors
sillonnant mais je voulais juste voilà
donc voilà donc il ya la rénovation vous
avez bien compris du quartier des
acacias qui nous paraît qui nous paraît
très important et donc ce pôle
multiservices également tout ce qui est
portail pour les parents au niveau
portail citoyen portail familles
puisqu'on a un site internet qui a date
des années 90 2000 qui est plus du tout
adaptée aux besoins des parents on a
aussi l'idée si l'idée que pour la garde
des enfants s'assoient pas un choix
financier
ddd d'aider les parents à voir le mode
de garde qui choisit subventionnée par
la mairie pour que ce soit la crèche la
crèche privée la crise publics ou les
assistantes maternelles on se retrouve
avec le même la même main au
portefeuille
voilà donc on a un projet citoyen qui a
été monté par des citoyens de manière
aussi modeste qu'il soit il beaucoup
beaucoup de gens son nouveau nom not
least beaucoup de gens ont beaucoup
d'idées pour avancer voilà donc c'est un
citoyen qui vous parle ici la science
des citoyens monsieur fisher pour
terminer vous aviez beaucoup d' avance
dans ce débat on va vous laisser 30
secondes pour conclure pour équilibrer
plutôt ce débat vos mots de conclusion
pour pour cela et en trente secondes
c'est difficile non mais il faut
respecter l'équité peu plus de 30
secondes et vous accorderez un reportage
à bestiaux girard si vous voulez par la
suite
tout d'abord monsieur girard vous êtes
un citoyen mais je suis aussi un citoyen
il faut voir les choses ainsi comme ça
nous sommes en république
ça nous tous des citoyens ma liste est
aussi citoyenne que la vôtre j'ai
personnes dans le quarté je dirais dans
des partis politiques je ne suis moi
même pas encartée dans les partis
politiques il a un passé politique
bien sûr c'est un homme de gauche
monsieur girard et ce à tous les
poignets rien le savent les jamais menti
sur je dirais sur mon parcours politique
en revanche la liste elle est aussi
citoyenne que la vôtre elle s'est faite
aussi avec les quoi n'y a rien et elle
s'est fait depuis des années avec les
poignets rien alors moi je voudrais
simplement revenir pour vous laisser 20
secondes sinon on va vraiment
d'excellents énormément pour pour
conclure sur le fait que moi je veux
redonner un élan culturel
la première année en culturel et
associatif on mettra en place un service
dédié aux associations justement
véritable service dédié aux associations
on fera en sorte que l'espace daudet
soit beaucoup plus tourné vers la ville
qui ne l'est à l'heure actuelle on
envisage la création d'un deuxième lieu
culturel associatif et qui sera géré de
manière participative voyez la
citoyenneté elle est là aussi sera géré
de manière participative par les
associations et puis on mettra en place
ceci un véritable pass culture voilà un
peu quel est notre perspective bien
entendu un en ce qui concerne
poignet ensemble je dirais soizic sont
de continuer cet élan nous avons
commencé à donner au mois de décembre
on va on va arrêter là ce débat il ya
environ une minute suivante différentiel
non je préfère regarder - 1 minute 36
est possible allez-y voilà donc au
niveau de la culture va pas laisser les
seuls abandons avec avec notre liste
l'idée c'est de créer vraiment un pôle
culture à l'espace daudet de rassembler
toutes les associations 20.16 et
pourrait ainsi les pressions ce n'est
pas le genre monsieur fisher c'est ce
que nous ferons aussi trouver vous
cultivez que deux ans face à tant d
monsieur monsieur fisher vous êtes déjà
très en avance c'est le bilan des
équipes passé et ça alors et nos bilans
maintenant oui mais on se laisse parler
sinon tout s'il vous plaît les embrasser
le bilan des équipes passante sont
écoutés parce que girard c'est le bilan
des équipes passaient moi je parle
maintenant de cette semaine de la
semaine dernière de la semaine
précédente vous étiez maire comment
montrer clairement moi ce qui m'ennuie
beaucoup avec avec l'équipe monsieur
fisher c'est parfois le fait de pas
mettre les bonnes choses au bon endroit
il ya des écoles de danse il ya des
écoles de théâtre parfois nous pacser à
l'espace daudet parce que ça ne
satisfait pas actuellement le directeur
actuellement de de l'espace daudet c'est
juste non mais c'est juste inacceptables
mais si bien sûr c'est que je voulais
pas le débat le d'evans arrêtera smala
on la construit on va regarder une
dernière fois les femmes seront des
monsieur fisher ben désolé on va arrêter
c'est la politique de l'équipe
précédente tout ça et cécile et moi je
suis content je suis shirt et
aujourd'hui on laisse 30 secondes
vraiment de conclusion et on arrête ce
débat s'il vous plaît alesis propos
vraiment l' équilibre et monsieur gérard
bon enfin pour terminer donc pas faire
que ma conclusion la malaisie nature
donc j'en reprendrais pas le terme qui
est employé à candidatures des
candidatures populaire de déjean 2
coignières tout simplement
j'espère qu'ils vont nous faire
confiance nous continuerons la
continuité du service de monsieur fisher
n'y aucun souci là-dessus nous apportons
beaucoup de choses nouvelles et on les
attend donc à notre prochain débat
public mardi ils disent voilà merci à
vous deux on regarde une dernière fois
les temps de parole qui se sont
rééquilibrés avec cette dernière prise
de parole débat touche à sa fin un débat
a retrouvé un jeu le précise en replay
sur tv 78 points comme et sur notre
application mobile est également en
podcast audio sur radio sensations
yvelines les débats du scrutin des
municipales continue sur les antennes de
tv 78 et de radio sensations et vie
[Musique]